Welcome to another very special bonus episode of how we made your mother the bonus episodes we are referring to as general questions, general questions, there's always a delay I don't know.
欢迎收听又一期非常特别的《老爸老妈浪漫史》幕后制作特别番外篇，我们称之为“常规问题”栏目，常规问题，总会有点延迟，我也不知道。
We can't sink this we have to get in person and do this.
我们不能这么干，我们得去现场录。
I'm joined as ever by my friend Craig Thomas hello Craig.
和往常一样，我的朋友克雷格·托马斯也加入了进来，你好，克雷格。
Hey Craig co-created the show how I made your mother with with our buddy, Carter Bayes.
嗨，克雷格和我们的好兄弟卡特·贝斯一起创作了这部剧《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
And we're answering all the general questions, general questions about episode six, the slutty pumpkin.
我们要回答所有关于第六集《性感南瓜》的常规问题。
So Alec, hello Alec Lev, our co-producer or our producer and friend.
那么阿莱克，你好，阿莱克·莱夫，我们的联合制片人，或者说是制片人和朋友。
What do you got for us?
你给我们准备了什么？
What did the listeners want to know about?
听众们想知道什么？
The listeners, I would call these more broad questions about the writing.
听众们，我觉得这些更像是关于编剧方面的宏观问题。
Obviously, let's just go ahead and respect the fact that 30 people just wanted basic origin stories.
显然，让我们先尊重这样一个事实：有30个人只是想知道基本的起源故事。
Here, it was not a Chiquita banana costume.
这里，它不是一个香蕉奇塔 costume。
It was not a plum.
它不是一个李子。
It was a pumpkin where did this come from, but I'll broaden out a little bit into the writer's mind here.
它是一个南瓜，这是怎么来的，不过我在这里会稍微把话题扩展到编剧的想法上。
So you kind of have the ideas of, oh, let's do a Halloween show.
所以你们大概有这样的想法，哦，我们来拍一集万圣节的节目吧。
You have the Ted is going to doggedly, you know, stay at this party because of this girl and then you have a slutty pumpkin.
你们有泰德会死守，你知道的，因为这个女孩而坚持在这个派对上，然后你们有一个性感的南瓜。
Do you remember kind of what influenced, what came first, what was the inspiration for the whole thing?
你还记得是什么影响了这一切吗，哪个先出现，整个构思的灵感是什么？
I mean, for sure, the inspiration was, let's rip off, it's the great pumpkin, Charlie Brown, for sure.
我的意思是，当然，灵感就是，我们抄袭一下吧，就是《查理·布朗的万圣节南瓜》，肯定的。
For sure, it was that and then it had to be a pumpkin.
肯定的，就是那个，然后它必须是个南瓜。
So that decision was made for us when we decided to rip off, rootlessly rip off charselds.
所以当我们决定抄袭、肆无忌惮地抄袭查尔斯（·舒尔茨）的时候，这个决定就已经为我们做出了。
But yeah, it was really that.
但确实，就是那样。
It was really from that initial idea.
真的就是源于那个最初的想法。
And just the thought, you know, this is an episode about Ted having faith and Ted sort of doing this ritual each year and a way to get to know Ted better.
还有那种想法，你知道的，这是一集关于泰德保持信念，泰德每年都举行这种仪式，以及一种更好地了解泰德的方式。
But yeah, really, it was, it was peanut.
但真的，就是，就是《花生漫画》。
We have peanut to think.
我们要感谢《花生漫画》。
It's also like, did you ever read Craig Jeff Tweedie's book How to Write a Great Song?
这就好像，克雷格，你读过杰夫·特维迪写的《如何写一首好歌》那本书吗？
I own it and have not read it.
我有这本书，但没读过。
Yeah, he has this writing exercise where he says like, I forget what he calls it, but he says like, write down like 10 baseball terms and then write down 10 adjectives.
对，他有一个写作练习，他说，我忘了他是怎么称呼的，但他说，写下10个棒球术语，然后再写下10个形容词。
So you end up with like lovely steel or like frightful bases or something like that where you're trying to like put weird words together that trip something like kind of delightful in your head.
所以你最后会得到诸如“可爱的钢铁”或者“可怕的垒包”之类的词组，也就是你试图把奇怪的词语组合在一起，在你的脑海中引发某种奇妙的化学反应。
And I feel like slutty pumpkin is one of those.
我觉得“性感南瓜”就是其中之一。
It's very satisfying to say.
说出来感觉非常满足。
It's satisfying but it also you go, how does a pumpkin get slutty?
很满足，但同时你也会想，南瓜怎么会变得性感呢？
Like what's happening with the mechanics involved a pumpkin being slutty.
就像南瓜变性感背后涉及的机制到底是怎样的。
But also, you know, Barney's theory about like everything gets sluttified.
但同时，你知道的，巴尼关于一切都会被“荡妇化”的理论。
Is that what is that would be the word?
是这样吗，是这个词吗？
Yeah, I think this is more or less.
对，我觉得差不多就是这样。
Yeah.
对。
Oh, I also, I'm reading this Melissa Fibos book who's a great writer called Girlhood where she talks about a slut, the origins of the word slut.
哦，还有，我正在读梅利莎·费博斯的书，她是一位伟大的作家，书名叫《少女时代》，她在书里谈到了“荡妇”这个词的起源。
I think it used to be like about housekeeping like when things were like left around your house was really slutty when it was messy.
我想它过去好像是指家务，比如东西乱扔在家里，如果家里很乱，就会被认为很“slutty”。
And then it morphed.
然后它就演变了。
Yeah, And then it morphed into this kind of thing.
对，然后它就演变成这种意思了。
So anyway, that's just what I'm reading lately.
所以不管怎样，这就是我最近在读的内容。
I like it's very poetic.
我喜欢它，它非常具有诗意。
It is.
确实是的。
There's something about that phrase slutty pumpkin.
“性感南瓜”这个短语有一种独特的魅力。
It's sort of like this.
它有点像这种。
It's very sticky.
它非常“黏人”。
It's sticky.
很黏。
It sticks in your head.
它会黏在你的脑海里。
It is.
确实如此。
It's sticky.
它很黏。
That's slutty pumpkin.
这就是性感南瓜。
This is just making it even more parable sounding more than we say.
这听起来更像是一个寓言，甚至超过了我们所说的。
But yeah, no, it definitely came from it.
不过，是的，不，它绝对是来源于此。
It definitely came from from peanuts and just loving.
它绝对是来源于《花生漫画》以及对它的喜爱。
We, you know, it was a bunch of writers in a room that all grew up watching.
我们，你知道的，那是一群聚在一个房间里的编剧，大家都是看着《查理·布朗的万圣节南瓜》长大的，如果我没记错童年的记忆的话，这节目以前好像是在哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）播出的。
It's a great pumpkin Charlie Brown, which I think used to, I think that I was used to earn CBS if I'm remembering my childhood correctly.
如果我没记错童年的记忆的话。
So we thought we're on CBS.
所以我们当时想，我们在CBS。
We will own this.
我们要把这个做成我们的标志。
We will just be part of that CBS Halloween tradition.
我们要成为CBS万圣节传统的一部分。
And yeah, it was just our love letter to that.
是的，这只是我们写给它的一封情书。
And Linus and Ted, there's such a comparison to the hopefulness of those two characters.
莱纳斯和泰德，这两个角色的那种充满希望的精神之间有着如此巨大的相似之处。
It also reminds me, Craig, that or it makes me think that you guys were big fans of this holiday classic.
这也让我想起，克雷格，或者让我觉得你们是这个节日经典的超级粉丝。
But in your love of it and your homage to a holiday classic, you made another holiday classic.
但在你们对它的热爱和对节日经典的致敬中，你们又创作了另一个节日经典，
right?
对吧？
Like it's like a remix or a re-conceiving of something that you put your own stamp on, and it becomes its own thing, right?
就像是一个混音版或重新构思的版本，你们印上了自己的烙印，然后它变成了它自己的东西，对吧？
It's like Shakespeare like stole all these plots and updated them and made them his own, you know?
就像莎士比亚偷了所有这些情节并更新它们，让它们成为他自己的东西一样，你知道的？
Like if Kid Rock had made good songs, that sort of it.
就像如果摇滚小子（Kid Rock）能写出好歌一样，差不多就是那回事。
Sorry, Kid Rock.
抱歉，摇滚小子。
No, that's thrilling.
不，这太令人兴奋了。
We loved a good Halloween episode, because it's just it gives you something to start with.
我们很喜欢拍一集精彩的万圣节剧集，因为这能给你一个开端。
You're in a world to begin with.
你从一开始就身处一个世界中。
It's not from a standing star.
不是从零开始。
You're in some goodwill.
你自带一些好感度。
People are just excited.
人们本来就很兴奋。
Like today's Halloween or more or less Halloween.
就像今天是万圣节或者差不多是万圣节。
And we're seeing this TV show about it.
而我们正在看一部关于它的电视剧。
There's just something just you're off to the races.
这就有一种你已经蓄势待发的感觉。
We never shot away from.
我们从不回避这个。
I missed it whenever we didn't do it.
每当没拍成的时候，我都会觉得遗憾。
And also there's a weird stuff that happens when people put on costumes.
而且当人们穿上服装时，会发生一些奇怪的事情。
And yeah, you know, your clown can come out or your demons can come out or What was the one of my favorite Halloween gags on the show was when they were going to go as the breakfast club.
而且，你知道的，你内心的小丑可能会释放出来，或者你的恶魔可能会释放出来，或者剧中最让我喜欢的万圣节搞笑桥段之一是什么呢，就是他们打算扮成《早餐俱乐部》。
But everyone dressed up as Joe.
但所有人都扮成了贾德·尼尔森（Judd Nelson）。
Oh my God.
噢，天哪。
That's one of my favorite jokes.
那是我最喜欢的笑话之一。
It's such a great funny joke.
这是一个太棒、太搞笑的笑话了。
And it's such a like kind of just for jet exers, you know?
而且这绝对是一个只属于X一代的梗，你知道吗？
Yeah.
对。
Such a good joke.
太棒的笑话了。
Yeah.
对。
There's an age cutoff for that joke.
这个笑话有一个年龄门槛。
But if you're in the red zone, you love that joke.
但如果你正好在那个受众范围内，你就会爱死这个笑话。
You've covered a bunch of things.
你们已经聊了很多内容了。
I just want to shout out some of our listeners here.
我只是想在这里感谢一下我们的听众。
Danny Hagueney asked, what is the inspiration for the slutty pumpkin and Gabe Silva one said, can you explain the connection or influence of, it's the great pumpkin Charlie Brown on this episode.
丹尼·哈格尼问：“‘性感南瓜’的灵感是什么？”加布·西尔瓦问：“你能解释一下《查理·布朗的万圣节南瓜》这一集对本剧的联系或影响吗？”
So there you go.
所以就是这样。
And then also Nora Ken Tanar asked, can you talk about the challenge of holiday centered episodes and why or how you chose specific holidays to depict like Halloween and Thanksgiving in particular?
然后还有诺拉·肯·塔纳问：“你能聊聊以节日为中心的剧集的挑战，以及为什么或者如何选择特定的节日来描绘，尤其是万圣节和感恩节？”
I would say something about that, which is just that you were so excited if you had a great idea for a Halloween episode or a Thanksgiving episode or Christmas episode.
关于这一点我想说的是，如果你对万圣节、感恩节或圣诞节有一集绝妙的创意，你会感到无比兴奋。
But if you didn't, it was very daunting.
但如果你没有，那就太令人头疼了。
And that's why some years we did them and some years we didn't.
这就是为什么有些年份我们拍了，有些年份我们没拍。
It was like, because we did a couple good ones early.
就像是因为我们在早期拍了几集很棒的。
We did a couple really good holiday themed episodes in the first couple of seasons.
我们在前两季里做过几个非常棒的节日主题单集。
And when it got a few, a few in and was like, we are not going to live up to our own, not only are we going to not live up to the grand tradition of a Thanksgiving episode, we're not going to live up to the one we did a year ago, then we just wouldn't do it because we're scared.
而当拍了几季之后，就会觉得，我们不仅达不到自己定下的标准，不仅无法延续感恩节单集的美好传统，甚至连一年前拍的那集都比不上，那我们就不拍了，因为我们怂了。
We're like, we're going to not clear our own bar.
我们觉得，我们肯定没法超越自己创下的标杆。
So it was was both great if you could kind of use the momentum of a holiday to tell a story, and yet daunting if you didn't have a story that kind of was worthy of it.
所以，如果你能借助节日的势头来讲故事，那自然极好；但如果你没有一个配得上节日的故事，那就让人望而生畏了。
And that's probably, you can go year by year and see the ones where we've clearly followed me to have a good enough idea.
而且大概也就是这样，你可以一年一年地看过去，就能发现哪些单集是我们明显觉得有一个足够好的点子才拍的。
You know, this is just the actor perspective, but it also translates to the writers.
你知道的，这只是演员的角度，但这也同样适用于编剧。
You would do these holiday episodes and you would feel somewhat festive because in the fictional context, you were celebrating the holiday, but we were recording a Halloween episode in September, right?
你会拍这些节日单集，你会觉得多少有点节日气氛，因为在虚构的情境中，你在庆祝节日，但我们在9月份就在录制万圣节单集了，对吧？
And you do your Thanksgiving episode October.
你在10月份拍感恩节单集。
And you do your Christmas episode in November.
你在11月份拍圣诞节单集。
So you're always like six weeks ahead of the holiday.
所以你们总是比节日提前大约六周。
Yeah, it feels like the holiday already happened.
对，感觉节日好像已经过去了一样。
Yeah.
对。
That's really funny.
这真的太搞笑了。
It's true.
确实如此。
You feel like, yeah, you're sort of weirdly off-kilter.
你会觉得，对，你整个人处于一种诡异的错位状态。
You're living in your own universe where Christmas already happened.
你生活在自己的宇宙里，圣诞节已经过完了。
It's, but there's something kind of great about that too.
这，不过这种感觉也有点棒。
Christmas, it would just set this tone of it would get you in the spirit in November and then that would sort of last.
圣诞节，它会奠定一种基调，让你在11月份就进入状态，然后这种感觉就会持续下去。
I always liked that.
我一直很喜欢那样。
But the whole set sort of felt Christmasy after that, even though it was like November 5th.
但此后整个片场都有了一种圣诞节的氛围，尽管当时大概才11月5日。
I want to say one other thing, Alec, which is just, I think we're going to talk about the episode proper, the episode about this episode, episode, rather than this.
亚历克，我还想说另一件事，那就是，我觉得我们要谈谈正片了，也就是关于这一集的单集，也就是这一集本身，而不是这个。
I forgot to shout out and just wanted to forget Brenda Shea, who wrote this episode, very funny writer, wrote on him for a few seasons, went on to write for a bunch of other cool shows and she wrote the Pixar movie Elemental, really talented, cool funny writer, and very much invented the drink, the Tootsie Role, in this episode.
我刚才忘了解谢了，我本想感谢布伦达·谢（Brenda Shea），她是这一集的编剧，一个非常搞笑的编剧，在剧组当了几季编剧，后来又去给一堆其他很酷的剧集写剧本，她还写了皮克斯的电影《疯狂元素城》（Elemental），真的是个才华横溢、很酷又搞笑的编剧，而且她可以说是发明了这一集里的那款饮料——“吐司卷”（Tootsie Roll）。
And the Alec, it looks like from the shock expression of synergy on your face.
亚历克，从你脸上那震惊又默契的表情来看。
He's drunk on Tootsie Role.
他已经喝了那款“吐司卷”醉了。
He's been knocking him back to zeros all day.
他一整天都在一杯接一杯地猛灌呢。
And people would write us, well, first of all, this episode spawned a trillion Halloween costumes.
大家会写信给我们，好吧，首先，这一集催生了成千上万个万圣节服装。
And just to say this, even now, 10 years, 11 years up, it's shown off the air.
顺便说一句，即使在现在，节目停播10年、11年之后。
We got these costumes, I guess.
我想我们还是收到了这些服装。
People has ramen sparkles, people has a slightly pumpkin, people's heads hanging Chad, people make those home in hanging Chad outfits.
有人扮成拉面闪闪发光，有人扮成小南瓜，有人扮成悬挂的选票（Hanging Chad），人们还自己制作那些悬挂选票的服装。
I've seen so many Josh.
乔治，我见过好多这种服装。
I hope you've seen those two.
我希望你也见过。
This past Halloween someone sent me that they were going as that.
这个万圣节刚过，就有人发消息说他们打算扮成那个样子。
And that's amazing that that came from the episode.
这太神奇了，那是从这一集里诞生的。
And also Brenda Shea, I know that her invention of that drink, I know that a lot of him in fans tried to mix that drink.
而且还有布伦达·谢，我知道她发明的那款饮料，我知道有很多《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝尝试去调制那款饮料。
And I think said it was quite delicious.
并且我觉得他们说味道相当不错。
I have no excuse to make for myself that I've not yet tried that.
我到现在还没试过，实在没什么借口可找。
I will go immediately and between this and the next episode recording gets super hammered and just just see what happens.
我马上就要去，在录制这一集和下一集之间把自己灌得酩酊大醉，然后看看会发生什么。
You know, but the hanging chat, it could be argued the hanging chat costume is the only good thing to come out of Bush v Gore to circus 2000.
你知道的，不过悬挂选票，可以说悬挂选票服装是2000年布什对阵戈尔事件中唯一的好东西。
Do you know the moment episode where they're talking about like the political relevance of it?
你知道剧里他们谈论其政治相关性的那一幕吗？
And they're like, it's a sad commentary that we know one remembers the hanging chat anymore than the parents.
他们说，这真是一个悲哀的讽刺，没人再记得悬挂选票，只记得父母了。
We revived it.
我们让它复活了。
And also look where we are now in modern politics.
而且再看看我们现在所处的现代政治。
Anyway, let's get back to the show.
不管怎样，让我们回到节目中来。
Let's just let's go right into it.
咱们直接开始吧。
Sophia Gomez won.
索菲亚·戈麦斯赢了。
Have you guys actually tried the Tootsie role drink in real life?
你们俩在现实生活中真的试过那个“吐司卷”饮料吗？
Curious if it's good and it Natalie, uh, Natalie, uh, I can't do it.
很好奇它好不好喝，还有娜塔莉，呃，娜塔莉，呃，我说不来。
Nantalya.
纳塔利娅。
Just a pitch.
随便猜一个。
Nantalya.
纳塔利娅。
Yeah.
对。
I'm going to pitch the right way to say that N-A-T-A-L-L-I-A-I-E-A-N-O-N-L-T-T-E, right?
我要说出正确的拼写方式 N-A-T-A-L-L-I-A-I-E-A-N-O-N-L-T-T-E，对吧？
I don't know what's going on.
我不知道这在搞什么鬼。
Keeps going.
继续。
Who invented the Tootsie role and Amy Wins, who came up with the Tootsie role along with Brenda Shea?
是谁发明了“吐司卷”饮料，还有艾米·温斯（Amy Wins），她和布伦达·谢一起想出了“吐司卷”的主意？
So, Brenda Shea, Brenda Shea, who often pointed out that her name sounded like the chorus of Cannonball by the breeders, Brenda Shea, Brenda Shea, anyway, I don't know what's happening.
所以，布伦达·谢，布伦达·谢，人们经常指出她的名字听起来就像The Breeders乐队的歌《Cannonball》的副歌，布伦达·谢，布伦达·谢，不管怎样，我不知道发生了什么。
I drank a touchy rill in between answers, but I don't know why I've never tried that drink.
我在回答问题间隙喝了一杯“吐司卷”，但我不知道为什么我从来没试过那款饮料。
You think the writers?
你觉得是编剧们吗？
Maybe one time we did it in the writers room.
也许有一次我们在编剧室里做过。
I think we did.
我想我们做过。
I think Brenda invented and we said, yeah, let's try it, and I've gotten a lot of good reports from people on the fans online who said they drink it every Halloween and it's great.
我觉得是布伦达发明的，然后我们说，好吧，我们试试看，而且我从网上的一些粉丝那里得到了很多很好的反馈，他们说他们每个万圣节都会喝这个，而且棒极了。
so I think Brenda really did an invent cocktail.
所以我认为布伦达确实发明了一款鸡尾酒。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了首小曲儿，要在纽约市唱给你听。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克·戈德曼（Alex Goldman），播客节目《HyperFixed》的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会倾听听众的烦恼并尝试帮他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：我30岁了，但很害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时不能调节车载音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也会解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么烦恼，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed podcast from Radio Topia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《HyperFixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或访问 HyperFixedPod.com 收听。
Josh, let me ask if you remember.
乔治，让我想想你是否还记得。
So now, again, we're on episode seven, trying to get into the mind of the actor back then.
所以现在，我们又来到了第七集，试着去体会当年演员的心态。
You are on this TV show, this is happening.
你正在出演这部电视剧，这一切正在发生。
And you get handed a script, that's like a, you know, it's very Ted Heavy.
然后你拿到了一份剧本，里面有，你知道的，有大量围绕泰德（Ted）的戏份。
It's also kind of a big grand Ted idea, right?
这也是一个非常宏大的泰德式构思，对吧？
I mean, I don't know if you could tell at the time, oh, this is going to be a big thing.
我的意思是，我不知道你当时能不能看出来，哦，这将会是一件大事。
But when you get a script like that, that's you heavy on a new show that you're on, did that go, oh, I'm so excited.
但当你拿到这样一份在一部新剧中以你为重心的剧本时，你当时的感觉是，哦，我太激动了。
There's a big thing for Ted to do here.
泰德在这里有一件大事要做。
You know, Greg Malins, I think, said something to me early on, was Greg on season one, or did he come on season two?
你知道的，格雷格·马林斯（Greg Malins）早些时候好像对我说过什么，格雷格是第一季就在，还是第二季才来的？
He came season two, Greg Malins, really funny writer, I could produce it from friends and came and was on having to run the starting and season.
他是第二季来的，格雷格·马林斯，一个非常有趣的编剧，我能从《老友记》里制作他，他来了之后就参与了这一季的运作。
I love Greg Greg.
我爱格雷格，格雷格。
Um, he had a bit of a like, I mean, he was so young, but he had such like elder energy.
嗯，他有点那种，我的意思是，他那么年轻，却有一种老成持重的感觉。
And I think something about like having written on friends for a lot of years gave us this kind of sitcom, Gravy Toss and, uh, yeah.
而且我觉得，在《老友记》里写了多年剧本的经历，赋予了我们这种情景喜剧的轻松从容，还有，是的。
Oh, big time.
哦，太对了。
He would tell me some things that were really calming.
他会告诉我一些让人非常安心的事情。
And I remember he said to me once, you can't worry about week to week, like whether you have a strong episode or good episode or you got the good jokes or not good jokes.
我记得他有一次对我说，你不能为每周的得失而焦虑，比如你这一集够不够精彩、是不是个好单集、你有没有分到好笑点或者不够好笑。
Like you just have to know that the vibe is good.
你只需要知道整体氛围是好的就行。
Like the show is working and if a show runs long enough, everyone gets their moment in the sun, everyone gets their arcs, everyone gets their romances, you know, you can see when even like a show like friends, you can see when they crack Joey, and they like turn their attention to Joey more, right?
就像这部剧正在顺利推进，如果一部剧播得够久，每个人都会迎来自己的高光时刻，每个人都会有自己的故事线，每个人都会有自己的浪漫情节，你知道的，你可以看到，甚至像《老友记》这样的剧，你能看出他们是什么时候摸透了乔伊这个角色，然后把更多注意力转向了乔伊，对吧？
And Matt LeBlanc like rose to the occasion, right?
而马特·勒布朗（Matt LeBlanc）也出色地完成了任务，对吧？
Like he wasn't just like, side character, they like explored some more stuff with him.
他不仅仅是个配角，他们还深入挖掘了他身上更多有趣的东西。
So, you know, I think you're always, there's always a negotiation between being a team player and having your ego kind of throw a temper tantrum.
所以，你知道的，我觉得你总是在做一件事：在做一个团队合作者和让自己的小本能发脾气之间进行权衡。
I think that coming from the theater, I always looked at being a part of like an ensemble as an honorable thing.
我觉得出身剧团的我，一直把成为集体（Ensemble）的一部分视为一件很光荣的事。
That's what I learned at NYU.
这是我在纽约大学学到的。
It's what I learned in the theater that even if you were the lead of the show, you were a part of a working organism and everyone had their part to play.
这也是我在剧团里学到的：即使你是剧里的主角，你也是一个运作中的有机体的一部分，每个人都有自己的角色要扮演。
And maybe I'm making myself sound more magnanimous than I was, but I certainly, sometimes there'd be episodes I remember where I was a little confused, matchmakers wanted them, right?
也许我把自己说得比实际上更高尚了，但我确实，我记得有时候有些单集会让我感到有点困惑，比如“红娘”那一集，对吧？
Which we're going to talk about soon, but where I was a little confused until the end.
我们马上就要聊到那一集，但在看到结局之前，我确实有点一头雾水。
Like Ted, you would always, you would often use Ted to land the plane, especially in early seasons, where he was the one who kind of like reminded people what we were doing here, reminded people with the stakes of the show, or reminded people that he was the faith keeper, you know?
就像泰德一样，你总是，你经常用泰德来稳住大局，尤其是在前几季中，他是那种提醒大家我们在这里做什么的人，提醒大家这档节目的利益相关，或者提醒大家他是信仰的守护者，你知道吗？
Yeah.
对。
And I felt like, in slutty pumpkin, there's just this classic, great scene between Ted and Robin and the roof at the end.
我觉得在《荡妇南瓜》这一集里，结尾处泰德和罗宾在屋顶上有一场非常经典、精彩的戏。
And I sometimes felt, you know, so I felt like we hadn't quite discovered, like, smarty pants, uh, college Ted, right?
有时我觉得，你知道，我觉得我们当时还没完全发掘出那种懂经的、呃，大学时期的泰德，对吧？
At this point.
在这个时间点。
Yeah.
对。
I thought he was really funny, but his comedic engine hadn't had totally been found yet.
我觉得他真的很好笑，但他的喜剧发动机当时还没完全被找到。
But what you had always been there from the start was his sincerity, his heart forward kind of deadness.
不过从一开始就一直存在的，是他的真诚，那种把内心放在前面的有些死心眼的特质。
And I always felt like gratified when you guys went back to that well and used me in this very particular way, which you did in this episode.
每当你们重新回到那个源泉，用这种非常独特的方式来使用我时，我都感到很欣慰，就像你们在这集里做的那样。
Yeah.
对。
I mean, that roof scene at the end, I feel like kind of restates the premise of the entire series and why we're watching it and who Ted is.
我的意思是，结尾处的那场屋顶戏，我觉得它某种程度上重申了整部剧的基调，以及我们为什么要看这部剧，还有泰德是个怎样的人。
this really great way.
以一种非常棒的方式。
Like, when Ted says that line that I'm not going to put sure I'm sure, but basically like, I know the Saudi pumpkins are not going to walk through the door at 243 a.m.
比如，当泰德说出那句台词——我不敢百分之百确定原话，但大意是——我知道那个荡妇南瓜在凌晨2点43分是不会走过那扇门了。
But this is going to places I need to sit and wait, basically.
但这就是我需要坐下来等待的地方，基本上就是这样。
And it's almost like an invitation to the viewer.
这几乎就像是对观众的邀请。
Like, this is what this show is.
就像，这就是这部剧的本质。
We will be entertaining while you wait.
当你们等待的时候，我们会带来娱乐。
We're going to be drunk on a roof at 245.
我们会在凌晨2点45分醉倒在屋顶上。
If you want to be drunk on a roof for nine years with us, this is the place to be.
如果你想跟我们一起在屋顶醉上九年，这里就是你要来的地方。
Yeah.
对。
There are a lot of people who write questions that were they just do great little summary, character summaries.
有很多人写了问题，他们只是做了很棒的小结，角色总结。
We've read one or two of them before and I kind of like to highlight them because people clearly did a lot of work to put this question together, which is nice.
我们之前读过一两个，我挺想重点提一下的，因为大家为了把这个问题拼凑起来显然花了很大功夫，这很好。
And so, yes, it's me underscore Justin says, this episode is probably the one that hooked me.
所以，是的，“it's me underscore Justin”说，这一集可能是让我入坑的那一集。
having listened to the podcast episode so far, it feels like this was one of those one-off episodes that encapsulates the whole series.
听了目前的播客单集后，感觉这就像是那种浓缩了整部剧集的特辑之一。
Ted's constant optimism, Marshall and Lily's loving support, Barney's annoyance, et cetera, optimism, and Robin coming at the end to be the centering point.
泰德持之以恒的乐观，马歇尔和莉莉充满爱意的支持，巴尼的烦人之处等等，这种乐观，以及罗宾在最后出现成为全场的中心。
In the moment when writing these episodes, do you have awareness of this or am I just romanticizing the writing experience?
在创作这些剧集的时候，你们对这一点是有意识的，还是我把写作经历浪漫化了？
I think we had an awareness.
我想我们是有意识的。
I think we wanted this to be a Ted defining episode and then a Robin-defining episode.
我觉得我们希望这一集能成为定义泰德的一集，然后是一集定义罗宾的剧集。
It was the first episode where we kind of opened the hood of kind of Robin's insecurities and her self-doubt even.
这是我们第一次掀开罗宾的不安全感甚至自我怀疑的盖子。
And the way Ted can kind of comfort her, puts him in kind of a different like relationship to her.
而泰德安慰她的方式，让他与她建立了一种不同的关系。
He's been seeking her out and kind of chasing her and now he's comforting her.
他之前一直在寻找她、追求她，而现在他在安慰她。
And she's even saying to him, yeah, you're a little crazy, but I kind of wish I had a little more of that crazy.
她甚至对他说，是的，你有点疯狂，但我真希望自己身上也能多一点这种疯狂。
And so that was, I think we had that premise.
所以，我觉得我们当时是有这个设想的。
I mean, you thought it's the peanut's idea, we'll use the peanuts kind of hook to show an episode where Ted seems crazy for having this faith that the way that Linus does, but in the end, faith is a good thing.
我是说，你觉得这是《花生漫画》的点子，我们利用《花生漫画》式的钩子来呈现一集这样的剧情：泰德因为怀有这种信念而显得很疯狂，就像史努比的奈纳斯那样，但最终，信念是一件好事。
And so I think that was like the through line all the time.
所以我觉得这就是贯穿始终的主线。
Okay, just two more, two more sort of small questions here.
好吧，还有两个，还有两个比较小的问题。
And we obviously know the answer to this, but you can talk a little bit about this.
我们显然知道答案，但你们可以稍微聊聊这个。
And Subhar, while Harashita asks, is McClaren's bar based on a real bar.
Subhar，也就是Harashita问，麦克拉伦酒吧是以现实中的酒吧为原型的吗？
McClaren's bar is totally based on a real bar.
麦克拉伦酒吧完全是以现实中的酒吧为原型的。
Down to the design elements, down to the color of the booth, down to the huge murals on the wall, the color of the green lamps on the bar.
从设计元素，到卡座的颜色，到墙上的巨幅壁画，再到吧台上绿色台灯的颜色。
And it was this bar that Carter and I spent a bunch of our early mid-20s going to that was two blocks away from late show with David Lunarman, where we worked and where the entire staff of and crew of that show went out and got super drunk every Thursday night.
这个酒吧是卡特和我二十多岁出头时经常去的地方，它离大卫·莱特曼晚间秀只有两个街区，我们在那里工作，那档节目的全体演职人员每周四晚上都会去那里喝得酩酊大醉。
And it was just a huge part of our 20s.
那是我们二十岁时代非常重要的一部分。
And so my clearance is a shout out to McGee is still a lab and kicking on 55th Street between Broadway and Ace, I believe.
所以麦克拉伦酒吧是对麦吉酒吧（McGee's）的致敬，它至今仍然开在百老汇和第八大道之间的55街上，如果我没记错的话。
And it's kind of the how I met from other bar.
它算是“老爸老妈浪漫史”的另一家酒吧。
They're very much leaned into it being the how I met from other bar.
他们非常乐意承认自己就是“老爸老妈浪漫史”里的那家酒吧。
So if you're ever in New York, you can go there.
所以如果你去纽约的话，你可以去那里。
You can probably drink it toots.
你大概可以喝到Toots。
You're a little I'm not sure exactly if it's a toots.
你有点……我不太确定它是不是叫Toots。
I know they have some drinks called like Robin Sparkles and other things.
我知道他们有一些叫“罗宾闪耀”之类的特调饮品。
The Minnesota title wave.
还有明尼苏达潮汐。
And we've been some fan events there and it gets crazy and packed and it's great.
我们在那里参加过一些粉丝活动，现场会变得疯狂且挤满人，感觉棒极了。
So that up there, if you're in NYC.
所以如果你在纽约，可以去那里看看。
Josh, just maybe a time now, because in the early days of this podcast, many years ago, we talked about the idea of your age now, looking back at the character at that age then and looking back at the portrayal of the character at that age and Craig writing of an older character, looking back at his younger character.
乔希，现在也许是个好时机，因为在这个播客的早期，很多年前，我们谈过这样一个想法：关于你现在的年龄，回看当时那个年龄的角色，以及回看对那个年龄角色的刻画，还有克雷格以一个成熟角色的视角回看他年轻时的角色。
I just want to pause over this now and just, You have thoughts now about Ted's optimism, whether it's too optimistic, not optimistic enough.
我想现在暂停一下，探讨一下，你现在对泰德的乐观有什么看法？它是不是太乐观了，还是不够乐观？
Do you like where he's going?
你喜欢他未来的走向吗？
How do you feel about Ted as a human, as a 30-year-old human, as now Josh, a 50-year-old human?
作为一个人，作为一个30岁的人，以及现在的乔希，一个50岁的人，你对泰德这个人有什么感觉？
Yeah.
对。
It's a great question.
这是一个很好的问题。
I look at him that I admire it.
我看着他，我其实挺佩服他的。
I think that it's kind of incredible to get to 27 or almost 30 and have that level of faith and naivete on some level.
我觉得一个人到了27岁或快30岁的时候，还能在某种程度上拥有那种程度的信念和天真，这简直有点不可思议。
But I think that Ted and not dissimilar for me, but in totally different ways, like life needed to tenderize him a bit.
但我觉得泰德——这跟我其实有相似之处，但方式完全不同——生活需要把他稍微揉捏柔和一点。
He needed to get heartbroken a little bit more.
他需要经历更多的心碎。
He needed to get scuffed up a little bit more.
他需要遭受更多的磕磕绊绊。
I think the best kind of optimism is not like a polyanna-ish denial of darkness or shadow, but one that actually incorporates it and says, life is hard, it'll knock you around.
我觉得最好的那种乐观，不是那种盲目乐观地否定黑暗或阴影，而是一种真正将其纳入其中并说：生活很艰难，它会重创你。
But also, I do have faith and I have faith not just blind faith in some sort of like benevolent you know, a hand that's going to swoop in and fix everything, but I have faith in myself.
但同时，我确实有信念，我拥有的不仅仅是对某种慈悲的、你知道的、会突然出现并解决一切的神奇之手的盲目信念，而是我对自己的信念。
I have faith in myself that I have instincts.
我相信自己拥有直觉。
I've surrounded myself with good people.
我身边环绕着好人。
I believe that the universe is a friendly place as Einstein said.
正如爱因斯坦所说，我相信宇宙是一个友好的地方。
You know, our the only choice we have.
你知道，我们唯一的选择。
That's the only the biggest question.
那是唯一最重要的问题。
Do we think the universe is friendly or not.
我们究竟认为宇宙是友好的，还是不友好的？
And so I think that it's like adorable, and I don't mean that in like a condescending way.
所以我觉得这很可爱，我说的不是那种居高临下的意思。
Like there is something adorable about his naive optimism, but I also can see up ahead, like there's some there's some rapids up ahead for him that he's going to have to navigate.
就像他那有些天真的乐观中确实有一种可爱之处，但我也能预见到前方，他前方还有一些激流险滩需要去涉足。
And you know, I imagine it's not unlike being a parent where you look at your kid and you want to create an incredibly safe world for them.
你知道，我想这跟当父母差不多，你看着自己的孩子，你想为他们创造一个极其安全的世界。
And you drop them off at college or they go to their first job and like you're not gonna be able to child-proof the world for them.
而当他们去上大学或找到第一份工作时，你发现自己无法为他们把这个世界变得对儿童完全无害。
Like, you know, did we talk Craig about, I might have told you, Gary Goldman has a great joke.
就像，你知道，克雷格我们谈过吗？我可能跟你说过，加里·戈德曼（Gary Goldman）有个很好的笑话。
You know, millennials like everyone gets a trophy and people say, well, if everyone gets a trophy, how are they gonna learn how to fail?
你知道，千禧一代就像每个人都能得到一个奖杯，人们会说，好吧，如果每个人都能得奖杯，他们怎么能学会如何失败呢？
And he says, oh, I don't know, Have you ever heard of life?
然后他说，哦，我不知道，你听说过生活吗？
You know, just like life will get you.
你知道，就像生活会收拾你的。
It'll get you.
它会收拾你的。
It'll get you no matter how kind of bubble wrapped you are as a young person.
无论你作为一个年轻人被保护得多么像在气泡膜里，它也一样会收拾你。
So I think that I really, you know, I love Nick Cave so much because he's had so much loss in his life and he's had so much hardship and he's incredibly magnanimous and thoughtful and compassionate and tender, you know, Because I think the hardness of life can either tend to us or harden us.
所以我真的，你知道，我太喜欢尼克·凯夫（Nick Cave）了，因为他的人生经历了那么多的失去，经历了那么多的艰难困苦，而他依然无比宽宏大量、深思熟虑、富有同情心且温柔，你知道的，因为我觉得生活的严酷要么会让我们变得温润，要么会让我们变得冷酷。
And I choose, my hope is that it tenderizes me.
而我选择，我希望它能让我变得温润。
But the temptation to harden up and get tougher and get a little folded armed in cynical is always there.
但是那种想要变得冷酷、变得强硬、双臂抱胸变得愤世嫉俗的诱惑一直都在。
The invitation's always there.
这种诱惑总是存在的。
So for me, Ted is just a reminder like in the last analysis, it's better to err on the side of faith.
所以对我来说，泰德只是一个提醒：归根结底，宁可选择相信信念。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me, all sins are forgiven.
请赦免我，一切罪孽皆被宽恕。
New York City.
纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted an executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》由乔希·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lem, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我、亚历克·莱姆制作，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point de Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是Point de Blue录音室的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面插图由约翰·莫罗创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你首选的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这确实对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lowly Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔希·拉德纳创作的《NYC》，特别感谢洛利·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳德。
Visit howwemadeyourmother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问howwemadeyourmother.com以注册我们的Substack邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
你也可以点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你的故事和提问是节目不可或缺的一部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' Muse Letters on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Riders 的 Muse Letters。
Read Craig Thomas' Published Pros at CraigThomasRider.com and you can subscribe to my Dead Father Society also on Substack.
在 CraigThomasRider.com 阅读 Craig Thomas 的 Published Pros，你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的 Dead Father Society。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解你如何为先天性心脏病研究筹款这一节目的持续活动贡献力量，请查看我们网站顶部的“创造改变”标签。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
本期节目的制作得到了 backyard ventures 的支持，营销由 Tink Media 提供。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
The real question, it just hit me.
真正的问题，我刚刚才意识到。
Am I in love with you or just new York City?
我是爱上了你，还是仅仅爱上了纽约市？